[Music]
even when a character is created
completely with CGI that doesn't mean an
actor is out of the job
the recent live-action version of Dumbo
featured a computer animated version of
the titular tiny big eared elephant and
the recent Dumbo might have felt more
real to you than the average visual
effects creation this guy this is Edmund
he's a creature performer and has been
since he was 14 years old
you might not know his face but you've
seen him on screen before under heavy
prosthesis or CGI he played Dougal in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
a body double for one of the dwarves and
Snow White and the Huntsman and one of
the caretakers in Star Wars the last
Jedi creature performers are actors who
specialize in playing all sorts of
characters whether real or fantasy
monster animal typically this involves
an actor under heavy makeup or in a
full-body suit a strange dog on top is
kind of like to be there and to give a
performance of the CG creatures or maybe
might be in a full prosthetic suit um it
varies from job to job to play Dumbo
Osmond wore no prosthesis just a few
simple suits because Dumbo was created
with CGI
it was his movement not his look that
was needed here
MPC film one of the VFX companies that
worked on Dumbo said that having an
actor there in a green suit helped
director Tim Burton with shot
composition so why not just use a simple
puppet or stuffed animal or even just a
head on a stick well actually they did
use what's known as a stuffy for a few
scenes these objects help the crew
figure out the lighting and camera
angles they also had an additional photo
realistic Dumbo sculpt which was used
mainly for lighting references on the
skin but having an actor there in a suit
helped make it easier to create Dumbo's
movements especially for some of the
movie's more difficult shots in fact
they worked so closely with the
actor that visual effects supervisor
Richard stammers could talk directly to
Osmond via in earpiece while he
performed they couldn't get every little
thing from Osmonds performance alone
Dumbo's expressiveness was truly a CGI
Marvel it took Osmond some time before
he was ready to play Dumbo and getting
the play a baby elephant
even one created with CGI isn't easy
movement was perhaps the key element in
nailing down this convincing and
invisible creature performance I mean
you're gonna quit no matter what you do
lose all your inhibitions and just go
for it Osmond had about four weeks to
train and worked about two to three
hours per day just walking around on
these arm extensions which are often
used for actors portraying a character
who walks on all fours he had to be
prepared for long days on set of walking
exclusively on extensions the struggle
would be on the sanctions days if you
don't get the rhythm right if you don't
do right arm left leg you end up walking
like a table and the play Dumbo he
couldn't simply walk around Osmond
really had to move like an elephant
every animal has its own unique
movements and mastering those movements
can make or break a creature actor's
performance for instance he played a
gorilla in 2013's Tarzan 3d in which he
donned a motion capture suit walking
like a gorilla and walking like an
elephant are two completely different
skills gorillas tend to leave with one
shoulder while walking or running they
can also walk on just their back legs
and hold their head similar to humans
while moving very heavy on shoulders so
it means when you walk in your on your
arm extensions you really do have to
kind of lead with your arms which is you
can imagine as humans is pretty
uncomfortable when you're used to
walking on your back legs in general a
gorillas movements are very similar to
humans thus making them easier to
emulate elephants are not as easy to
mimic Osmond had to create the same
shape of an elephant with his body
meaning he was always faced down with
his eye line to the floor and on top of
all that he was portraying a baby
elephant if you take on a job and you're
betraying a grown-up characters it's
quite simple because with adult
creatures or animals or humans they're
always quite certain in the way they
walk they have a clear direction where
they want to go and they're very certain
in their movement whereas with a baby
character like Dumbo the beauty of it is
is they're a sporadic they have such a
short attention span you know they might
do a couple of steps one way and then
all of a sudden they decide they want to
go another way while training he watched
hours of footage of real elephants to
get a sense of how they move he also
closely watched the original animated
Dumbo movie he took a lot of inspiration
from the film but it wasn't necessarily
the best way to learn how a baby
elephant moves when he watched the
original cartoon Dumbo is very light on
his feet and he's got these little
flicks and he's very he's very Disney
guide and he's very light getting the
movements down was also important for
another reason
making the cast feel like they're
working alongside a real elephant
Osmonds interactions with the actors
were key even though he doesn't have a
single line of dialogue the sounds Dumbo
does make aren't even him
[Music]
osmond also spent as much time as
possible off-camera bonding with the
cast especially the younger cast members
so their sense of wonder about Dumbo on
camera would appear even more convincing
one big factor affected how he
interacted with the rest of the cast his
suits being a creature actor also
involves wearing a lot of different
suits for this movie alone Osmond wore
three versions the first suit was called
a performance suit
this suit is built to look just like the
character it was used for scenes where
the actors needed to know the exact size
of Dumbo so for example in a scene in
which the actor is touching the elephant
then there was the more bare-bones
costume which they called the ant-man
costume on set this outfit came with
attachable ears and gave Osmond easier
movement it came in handy during scenes
that involved running or even a landing
because Osmond was walking on all fours
he was facing the ground most of the
time to help him see directly in front
of him the effects team installed a
camera rig inside these suits that would
give him a live feed of what was
happening right in front of him
the final suit was a special waterproof
bath suit which was made to get wet
during the scene where Dumbo is getting
bathed this was especially difficult for
Osmond
in his full-sized suit which also meant
I couldn't hear the director when he
shout action shout cut since the suit
was made to get soaked they couldn't
have a camera rig inside one of the
actors in this scene would give Ostman a
tap on the back to let him know his cue
each suit came in different colors which
were used depending on the shot for
instance in the scene were Dumbo's given
a bath they used a black costume as it
allowed the VFX team to separate Osmond
from the foam easier and while it might
look like he got erased from the shots
he was in his performance couldn't be
more important even when they don't have
any lines don't forget the people behind
the creatures